[Music]
excuse me she's been like crying for
hours sorry but this is a group for new
mothers on that sign out there it says
parents i'm a parent and i don't know
what the hell i'm doing
girl's got some stuff flying out of ass
and she can either hit you with a
streamer or she'll buckshot you
it's a quick walk i need help
i don't know how you're going to do this
if you've had only one parent i wish you
could have had your mom
because she would have been better at it
and mommy was the best
man go to sleep go to sleep
she's not working she's not a clapper
matthew darling we think you should move
back to minnesota you're all alone here
she needs
family raising a child it's a non-stop
all-day all-night affair i
look you look great i'm sad just to be
saying that you look
like a king king of the sling wake up
daddy
how does it look i think it's a new look
i think it's a new hairstyle that can
catch on if given a chance
you still love me madeline doesn't have
a mother to model after i am well aware
of what my daughter doesn't have you
think you can do this but you can't no
man you're right i can't do it but you
know what
i'm going to do it because i'm a father
[Music]
my god maddie you thank god the day i
got there in time
to hold her hand liz
i didn't get to hold her hand she was
gone and you
it's always just us other people have
more people
wrong i just want to do what your mom
would have wanted me to do
i promised them trying to make
everything
perfect but we don't have any control
wherever you are i want to go there
wherever you are i want to go there too
somebody's cutting onions or something
close to us or something i don't know
hey y'all gotta stop it oh
she'd be so proud of you
[Music]
two kisses
[Music]
hold on to me
[Music]
[Music]
you